[Music]  for high school seniors prom season  quickly approaching but of course the  economy is still in well it's in a  little bit of rough shape students are  on a very tight budget got those student  loans so to help ensure you still have a  memorable prom experience without  breaking the bank  here are some money-saving tips from our  prop master bill tall bill  [Music]  take it'll bedsheet dip it in glitter  boom prom dress  here's bit with another tip take a  flower staple it to your wrist boom  corsage go to an open-casket funeral  boom free suit skip the dance try to rob  a liquor store boom prom photo  one more take a helium balloon suck out  the air boom condom  [Applause]  you just need the balloon yeah yeah  trust me it just needs a look  you